what is going on everybody and welcome
to a cyber python 2077
video in this video we're going to be
tinkering with some computer vision
tasks
to see if we can achieve um some ai
functionality in cyberpunk 2077
to start unlike gta 5 which by the way i
know people are going to get some crazy
ideas uh with what's going on here
i'm just tinkering don't don't uh don't
read too far into it
but pretty much every game i play now i
think of like can this be solved with
the computer vision
of python and uh at least in this game i
think we can actually develop
the best ai in cyberpunk 2077 using some
pretty rudimentary
computer vision techniques so
um that's what we're going to do the bar
is pretty low so
uh so first of all i at least in this
game
unlike gta where cars are kind of like a
the main focus of the game i mean it's
like in the title that you steal cars
uh whereas in this game actually
kind of being on foot is is the more is
the bigger element
in this game um and then so i kind of
thought
like could we is it possible that we
could still navigate on foot like
through a city
um and and if i
could do that or if so like how how
might we actually just go about like
doing it
so then i started thinking okay well at
least on foot you can follow that
the the pathing that the game just gives
you and for the most part it appears the
pathing is pretty good
so if you wanted to navigate on foot in
this game with a program
you really just need to follow the
mini-map so
um so then it was like okay well how
would we
how do we follow the minimap what would
we do from there so i kind of just want
to run through
um what i think is at least a pretty
valid methodology for
automatically walking around in the game
of cyberpunk 2077
so the first order of business will be
to grab the screen
and then also we need something to do
direct input
both in the form of key presses but also
mouse movement on the screen so you
can't use something like pi auto gui
to input keys or to move the mouse
because that it's not the right input
type
basically for the game it won't
recognize what you're doing
so um so we need those two things and it
turns out with the
python plays gta series we got both of
those things
so let me pull up those i will put links
to both
in the description but here we have the
grab screen script
and then we have the keys now with grab
screen what this forces us into is
selecting basically the region that we
want to pull from
there are other methods you can also
there are some methods where you just
input the
name of the window right and it's much
less code than than what this is
uh the problem with that is at least for
me like i don't know all of like
all what's going on here but the biggest
thing is frame rate
we need the most frame rate as possible
so
um this still seems to be the fastest
way of
of getting those frames and reading
those frames so um this is the method
i'm going to use and then keys this was
written by daniel
just to let us control both the mouse
and the keys so i'm going to grab these
two i will put links to both in the
description so if you want to follow
along you can also if you want to follow
along in some other game
you totally can you don't have to run
cyberpunk 2077 to follow along
lots of games have mini maps lots of
games have pathing on the map
you should be able to use all of the
same techniques that we're going to use
here with
like any game that you want just
hopefully the pathing is decent
so at least in this game the path is on
the sidewalk
if you're on foot and then if you're on
a car the paths will be on the road
but even if there weren't pads like for
example like with a car
you could drive a car and you would know
where the road is based on the map um
oh i'm not showing the game so a couple
of things first of all if you hear all
my fans going that's because this game
makes the cpu
get very hot and fans go burr and
um and then uh because of this full
like the game and all that stuff uh it
becomes kind of challenging to show
uh all the windows i want to show so i
kind of have to navigate these windows
via obs which i'm recording
so sorry if i don't pull up the window
quickly or
forget to pull it up and i'm trying to
show you something it's just going to
happen but
anyway what we're going to try to do is
we're going to try to follow this yellow
path but
yeah you could in theory like if you
look at the mini map here
all the roads are marked with this like
blue color and that's
the same across the game so different
games are going to have different kind
of
methodologies for showing paths and
things on the mini map but
in general they tend to be pretty
standardized
in that specific game so anyway what
we're going to try to do
is follow that yellow path so the first
order of business we need to see the
game so we grab the screen for the game
then we need to see just the minimap so
then we're going to use a region of
interest with
um just opencv slice get just the
minimap
then we want to see the path right so
then we're going to mask and find that
yellow color
and then we'll go from there we'll try
to walk along that path using some sort
of technique
i'm sure there's many ways that this
could be done i'm just going to do
the way i came up with so uh okay so
let's get over to
our code here let me pull up sublime
cool all right so this is just some
starting code
basically it's just gonna grab the
screen for 100 frames again this is the
region this is going to vary depending
on the resolution of the game
where is the game is it running full
screen do you have many screens do you
have one big screen
is it a wide screen so on so um the
region that you select from and the
resolution is going to vary depending on
the game
so just note that when we pull it it
will be in bgr we're going to convert to
rgb
and then i'm just going to resize it to
something a little smaller
because we're going to display it and
there's no need to display the exact
same high resolution version
but let's go ahead and just kind of run
that show you uh what we have so far
hopefully it pops up it does great let
me move everything
out of the way and there we have we can
see that yep we are indeed pulling it at
a decent frame rate i wouldn't want to
play at that frame rate but
um it's at least enough that we okay we
could work with this
all right it's not uh two frames a
second so
okay now that we have that uh let me
pull up
sublime and what is the oh i ha did i
have it up or oh i had it up already and
then we were looking at the
it's going to continue it's going to
continue um okay so
um okay so we'll just continue working
so the first thing we want to do
is grab the mini-map so the first kind
of task is to just run through this path
so i'm actually just going to make a new
function we're going to just call it
define
pathing it's going to take in um
a map or let's call it minimap i don't
want to
steal the name map from python uh
it'll take a mini map and it's going to
just like do stuff for now we'll just
say pass
so we want to first grab that mini map
so before we do this like resize here
in fact i'm going to comment comment
comment out
we want to grab the the region of
interest that we're interested in
actually i already have the region of
interest that i want to use so
i am going to copy and paste it just
because it's silly to waste
time um but i'll at least explain it so
the minimap is a slice of the screen and
these are the x values and these are the
y values so it's going to be for x
it's from the 81 to uh 377 or actually
let me think about this i think it's
actually y x sorry
so so does that only make sense because
y starts at the t at the top
so it's actually y to your x so 81 to
377
and then um for the x coordinates it's
2181 to 24.69
um to to figure out what your
coordinates are
just trial and error it honestly just
paste in the ranges take your best guess
to start and then
hone it in so at least in this game uh
let's pull up the mini map
as you can see the mini map in cyberpunk
2077 is like not a perfect square
right it's a little distorted it's not
like a tilted square it's like
i don't know what but describe it
besides distorted it's not a perfect
thing so anything we do is not going to
be probably perfect in this case but
we should be able to still succeed so um
so that's our mini map we got the screen
and then we're going to pass that mini
map into pathing so then we're going to
say
pathing and we'll pass in minimap
and then we have code here so the first
thing that we want to do is we actually
want to detect that path
so i'm going to
i think we'll just i'm going to copy
this over
and explain what this is because again
your values are going to change if
you're using
some other game or something like that
i'm just assuming probably most people
watching are probably just simply
watching out of curiosity
and then some people are going to
probably apply it to another game and
then maybe one percent of you are
actually following along in cyberpunk so
i think i'll just do it this way so so
um
so for masking again kind of like
selecting this i'm going to be honest
with you
the way i go about doing it is the
following
so first of all when you mask you're
actually first going to convert to hsv
now hsv is huge saturation value and if
you look up hsv there are like hsv color
pickers and you might think i will just
use that
to figure out what the right values are
but they don't use the same range like
opencv
seems to use the range of 0-255 but
that's not actually a valid
hsv range so if anybody knows a better
way than what i'm about to show you
feel free to comment below but this is
the method i use
so zero 255 first order business like so
let me just let's just look at it real
quick
uh we don't have numpy let's import
import numpy as np save that
run it um okay so as you can see i'm
actually surprised that window came up
um so i'm using open or i'm using obs to
show you
like the different windows and it's
actually supposed to be looking for a
window called cv2 screen
but i saw it pop up so i'm not really
sure how that happened
but anyway this is what we get so it's
all white
so uh what this means is actually
everything matched right because
everything is in the range of 0 to 25
hue saturation and value so hue is your
color
saturation is your saturation value is
the value of that color
so um so the first order of business is
to figure out what is the hue
so so where in the range is this color
so the first thing i would do
is let's just set some large number um
approximately halfway there i know it's
not
quite right like one twenty
seven anyway not important 127.5
i don't know anyway so run that and we
can see
that in the hue of 150 to 255
it doesn't actually look like our path
is detected
so that means actually our path is in
the range of somewhere it's not in the
range of 150 to 255
so therefore it must be in the range of
0
to 150. so then
the next thing that we can do is we can
do the exact same thing
for saturation so we can say 150 to 255
we can run that again and sure enough
what we see
is okay great so we've filtered out
quite a bit we can still see our
character
color um and then we can see some like
some of the road it looked like
and just some general noise we still
want to kind of like filter those out so
again we'll just do the same thing again
okay we do 150 um
and then we'll run that again and then
okay at this point it looks like we've
actually filtered out basically
everything
except for the character on the map and
then
we have the path that we want well the
character color is like this like blue
let me pull it up real quick for you so
the character color on this map is a
blue
and the path is a yellow so we should
be able to filter that out like pretty
simply um so
the again the next thing i would do is
come back
to let me pull up my sublime show you
sublime
and then i would just continue adjusting
so i would continue bringing in
certain values so maybe here you know
you could make something
well first of all it's definitely a hue
issue right blue versus yellow
so it's not a saturation it's not a
value issue it's a hue so
probably i would say i don't know 75 to
150 that would be the first
next the first next step i would make i
don't know anyway let's try that
whoops i ran python instead
i'm not actually sure why weird
okay so anyway yeah boom done it
filtered out and now we have
just the path that we want to detect
okay now that we have that um
we have to talk about what is the actual
logic
that we intend to use so pulling up the
game
so what we really want to do is we want
to follow this path
um and and but we need to somehow
formulate
programming logic that will follow that
path for us based
visually on what the map looks like
so i think the best well there well okay
first of all
i mean we know like if our character is
looking like this
we know the character needs to look
right
and we know this because the character
is always like the mini map is always
forward for
character and we can see the path
is off to our right and then we know
this is correct because at least the
initial stages of this path
are directly in front of us so on the
map
that would translate to so let's just
pull that back up again
that would translate to the white pixels
basically
being directly in front of us well we
also can
surmise again the map is a little um
i can't think of the word now anyway the
map is not a perfect square
but we would say okay well probably the
target would be to have
white pixels in the in perfectly in the
middle
now the other problem we have is um
we if in this case if the white pixels
were perfectly in the middle
or we tried to make it as perfect or as
close to the middle as we could
probably the character would look like
this and then probably walk into this
poll right that's that's no good
we don't want that we want the character
actually to first go this way
and then turn so in order to achieve
that
um i think the best way about it is
actually rather than taking in the
entire
mini-map we zoom in even further
so the way i went about doing that
was i actually just make made a new
value called mini minimap and again i
just would um trial and error until i
got the value that i wanted
um but let me i already have a value
that i'd like us to use
possibly maybe
i thought i had the value but oh here we
go
i was about to have to just do it myself
um okay so let's pull this up
so i would say mini map and then mini
mini map
now i might as well just keep that on
hand because that's probably going to
come in use later at some point
but now rather than pathing mini-map
let's do pathing
mini mini-map save that um
it is still on screen let's run that
real quick and now it's so
small oh no i can't get it
uh it's like up in the corner uh i want
to make that
way bigger okay maybe i've got it
that way so anyway now we have the
minimap and now
as we if we zoom in enough we get just
like the few dots right ahead of us
so i think that's probably better so as
we approach hopefully i can make it in
time as we approach this
turn like if we centered those we would
probably like i'm trying to just walk
based on what i'm looking at on the
thing
i think that that's like good enough to
get around there um
so now we'll find out oh now it's gone
where's our path i look legit lost the
path on the uh
on the game for some reason anyway so
we'll have to handle for that kind of
stuff at a later date
um okay so uh once we have
um the so we're gonna work with those
like the smaller minimap of pixels once
we have those pixels we still have to
like
come up with the logic of okay how do we
know what center
how far off center are we and then when
we are off center how do we get back
on on center what do we do
so the first thing that we're going to
do is we're going to come over
after the mask yeah we'll just do that
so we need to find the coordinate
location
of all of the white pixels in that mask
so anything that matches the mask is
going to be a value of 255. everything
else will be
zero so we want to find where all the
pixels of 255 are
so to do that we're going to say matches
equals np.org where and then in here we
say where mask
equals to actually probably double
equals 255.
so that gives us all our matches so this
is going to be an array
of matches so for example let's print
uh matches let me
change the frames we're going to say 100
frames
and then we'll run map walking
so that showed up and then command
window
look at me hackerman okay so as we can
see it's kind of spamming out these
these locations
but as you can see at the end here we've
got it's just an array
of these coordinate locations for the
255 values
so what do we do with that well what we
really want
is for these coordinate values which by
the way these are
the in coordinates y x so it's an array
an image is an array and the first index
value
is going to be y and then the second one
will be x
and the one that we're interested in is
the x right because
the further um let's say uh you can't
see the game
uh let me do
this and this boom uh so in this case
like we want all those x's to be
perfectly in the center
but as it goes this way right the x's
will be
you know to the left so it'll be less
than
and then this would be perfectly
centered and then these would be like
greater than center values
so we want it to be in the perfect
center so first we want to know what is
perfect center
what are the current locations and then
like what is the delta
essentially and that will inform us
which way do we want
the mouse to turn so coming
back to sublime text and
i think we probably want
we'll want this window but i'm going to
i'm gonna get rid of it for now
so now i have to pull up sperm text
okay so we wanted to know so we've got
the matches
we now we want to know what the average
match was so i'm
just going to copy what i had before so
it was called mean y
and in this case it's going to be a
numpy dot mean
of the matches but we want just the x
elements and to do this with like a 2d
array for example it's going to be
colon comma whoops calling comma comma
the index that we want to use so it's
going to be colon comma 1.
okay so um so once we have that that
will be
the mean of all of the x values
of those matches so this will tell us
what the mean is and then we
just really we just want to know what is
our goal value
right so we're going to say uh target is
that what i could yeah call it target
equals and in this case it will be
whatever the minimap is
dot shape so the shape of the minimap
and again it's going to be
in i think yx yeah yx so we want to know
the
first element divide it by two that will
be our target
and i can't really decide i mean i don't
think it's going to be important that we
convert that to an int so like if it's a
float value for whatever reason no big
deal
i don't think it'll matter so we'll just
do that and i don't think
yeah so then finally we're going to say
our error
equals and we're going to say target
minus
whoops target minus mean y so
i'm back on like my main computer now
and um
now my main computer's keyboard is a
mechanical keyboard now with blue
switches
and i'm doing you guys a huge solid by
not using that on video
so i'm like trying to get used to using
this keyboard it's a pain um
okay so um air target
so rather than print matches let's print
the error
and then hopefully that will be somewhat
meaningful and give us values that we
want
so um we are printing out the screens so
i think we'll be good you can see that
um
and our error oh you can't see my
command window we pull up the command
window
and then finally let me just we don't
need to see sublime at the moment
so okay so this gives us our error so as
we're like
as we move this way the errors are
negative so if it's a negative that
tells us we need to move right
and then as we direct pull down the
error it appears to be working
as we want let me run it one more time
and then yeah so the error is positive
that means we need to move
left okay yeah so
great so now we are so close to
having having what we want so now all we
need to do
is basically walk and then move the
mouse as intended so
before we go make that mistake
let me um i'm going to import a time
and i'm going to come down here i'm
going to say 4i in
range of like three we're going to just
print i
and then time dot sleep and we'll sleep
for one
second now i have time to like set
everything up
because this is going to take control of
my mouse and my keyboard
and that will be really annoying if i'm
not actually set up to exactly what i
want to see
before that event occurs so
now um
okay so i'm going to take yeah i'll just
take this
and move this over so based on that
error what do we want to do we're going
to move the mouse
so i'm just going to paste in keys and
then direct mouse
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to move negative 1
times the end of the error because we
can't actually
um we can't move a float
number of pixels so we're going to just
move negative one
so we're gonna flip the sign of exactly
whatever the error is
and later we'll smooth that out or if if
there happened to be future videos
let's move that out but for now i think
that's fine
um and in this case it is x
y we only want to move the x uh axes at
the moment
so okay so at this point
we'll do that um
i guess we can do go ahead and just slap
in the direct key as well so once this
is done
we're gonna do uh keys dot direct
is it camel yes direct key and then it
will be w
and then when we're all done uh cv2
why would i show it so coming back here
um so yeah we have our sleep here
basically
we're going to input the w key just
before we start running through the
frames
and then here
we're going to release that key and then
destroy windows if for some reason you
are following along and the script
breaks
or you break the script or whatever
before the key gets released it's going
to stay depressed but all you have to do
is just hit the w key or whatever key
on your keyboard and it will release it
um
cool so yeah getting back to up here
once we've got
this defined we need to go ahead and
import keys
import keys as k and
then it's going to i think it's just key
yeah keys
equals k.capital keys
and then just empty there's no nothing
that we're gonna initialize in there
save this and i think that should work
so i think what i'll do is i'll start
off like off a little bit and then let's
see
let's see how that works so
run that zero one i wasn't totally not
ready
you can see at least it appears i didn't
move quickly enough did it no
oh and we got a okay so we got an error
we've got a couple of things
that's okay because you couldn't really
see what was going on i think i need to
make that timer
a little longer um okay so we got an
error
okay a couple of things happen so let me
pull up these
consoles so this is what we got it was
walking i
assure you um this is the area that we
saw i think it's because we actually
ended up walking beyond
the path uh that we intended to take um
so there was no path so we would want to
have some sort of handling for that
there's going to be times where
who knows what happens um sometimes when
you're filtering
the best mask for some reason even this
map i want to say is a little bit uh
transparent doesn't yeah it's a little
bit you can kind of see a little bit
through the map i don't know if i can
pull up
uh let's get rid of sublime like if you
look
um i'll put like a billboard behind it i
don't know if you can see that
but there is you can kind of see through
it anyway that can that can mess with
things it can change
the hsv values a little bit enough to
where you might not pick it up anymore
so you'd want to have some sort of
handling for that in general moving
around
or something like that can kind of help
uh to pick it back up but anyway we're
i'm not gonna try to fix that for now
the biggest thing was he just didn't
move in time so let me just run that one
more time
um zero one
two okay cool so i mean it
this guy's in the way so he's doing okay
he starts to try to turn and then he
misses it
he walks beyond his path that's why we
get that nan issue
uh the script breaks i just need to
press the w key and fix it
so let me get us back to where we want
to be
and we'll try that again so there's a
couple of changes that we want to make
in that will take us to sublime text
let me pull up spline here um
i think i want to make this maybe five
seconds for me
and then for the error movement
and error
i don't know times three okay cool
um and then i think that's probably good
enough
um we want to have some sort of trying
except for if this thing hits an error
but
for now whatever let's run that again
let me pull up close sublime
pull up this
and i think that's good enough let's run
it
okay so i'll start like this too let's
just see and also see like that path is
not
okay that's good enough i guess let's
see if he moves quickly enough
it's so juttery okay
yeah all right that appears to work we
could probably run it a little longer
um we might might even want to move uh
like a larger error but that at least
took the turn
decently again pretty jittery we would
want to smooth that mouse down
um but other than that i think it
actually worked pretty well
let me uh let us change
to let's do like 400 here
i'm gonna save that and i think that's
the only change i really need to make
let me get rid of sublime text
run that again cool
maybe oh there we go i forgot i said it
to five seconds
so even like it overshot that time but
still fixed itself that's fine
it actually follows that path really
well
see if he makes this turn
that's pretty good that's pretty good
this person is very scared
oh we just ran out of time okay cool so
that worked well although i will say i
was a little
curious what would happen uh with this
tree let's
let's just run it for 100 frames real
quick i think he's going to run into
this tree
i mean that's what it looks like so i
just changed frames to 100
i don't feel like showing it real quick
and then having to get rid of it
it just looks like the pathing is going
to go right into that
and it does is it going to make it oh we
still made it
uh that's so fun
okay i mean that's okay uh that's pretty
good
for some pretty basic code um
so yeah i think i think that's a pretty
good start to
um to to using the navigation especially
when
all we're doing is looking at the mini
map and turning our character based on
the map
at least through my playing um of a
completely reasonable amount of time of
this game i i believe the pathing is
actually pretty good like
it will usually map you around even
objects like this
uh for some reason i was kind of
surprised it didn't do that but
okay um but the next order of business
would be like for example if you run in
wow i thought i would run into this guy
i don't know sometimes you like go
through people and then sometimes you
run into people like what
i just like totally went through that
guy let's maybe they're standing still
let's see yeah so like sometimes you
just like run
i'm trying to do a demo here i don't
know
i i can't quite figure that out
i'm pretty sure you run into people but
um
and then he gets kind of stuck anyway i
assure you it happens sometimes
but so so having some sort of object
detection
on screen would probably help um to to
avoid people so
in general like if you saw there were
people here you could just sidestep a
little bit
and then you would get back on the
because even as you sidestep you just
saw like the thing
it should update at some yeah there we
go it updates so
you could sidestep a little bit wait a
few seconds and then it would update
and then you would have your new path so
you could probably get around it doing
that and i
i think you would be able to probably
navigate with a really high percentage
you know like 70 or 95
of the time i think that's enough to to
do everything on foot that you would
need to do on this game
um so that's pretty cool uh i think the
only
major downside is like if there if you
happen to be in an area that doesn't
have a sidewalk
it does put the path for you to walk
like literally in the middle of the
street that's kind of a problem
so so yeah but there's really nowhere
else for you to walk so i don't know i'm
not really sure
um okay i think that's a good stopping
point uh hopefully you guys enjoyed if
you have any ideas
uh or requests for like something that
we could do in this game
um yeah feel free to let me know uh if
you have ideas for like how we could
make it even better
you could let me know that as well i
definitely am going to try to apply
object detection onto here i'm curious
how well it picks up things i
i suspect we'll be able to pick up cars
and people
uh quite well with object detection like
just the basic tensorflow object
detection
so i'm kind of interested to see how
well that works um
also interested to see how much we can
stack on top of our gpu
without um completely dying so uh
okay so maybe some interesting things to
look forward to uh in the future i'll
probably just
continue tinkering on here questions
comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
otherwise i will see you guys in another
video
you